[Music]
bow earlier this week i posted
the question about facial hair and
appreciate the answers but to further
that question i've noticed so many
comics change their appearance from the
early days
to the day they hit it big can
appearance play that big of a role in
performing
well yeah i mean appearance does play a
big role
in the performance uh if you're wearing
a hawaiian shirt people are going to
assume one thing about you if you're
wearing a suit on stage people are going
to be assuming another thing about you
you know a lot of comedy hinges on
surprise and a lot of comedy
is that misdirect and you're building
assumptions on stage at all times
whether it is with a setup punch or
whether it is with how you look or how
you talk
and when you're walking out on stage
people are already
creating a story for you they're already
building assumptions about you before
you even say anything and that's all
based on your appearance
so your appearance really does matter
and
one comics i've changed their appearance
from the early days you know
that is also how humans are where humans
just
their appearance changes over the years
but i think it also comes especially
from a comedian standpoint
i think your appearance on stage also
comes with just more self-awareness on
stage something jeff foxworthy said in
our q a with him
was be mindful of how you're coming off
to the audience
and that can't and he said that he's
like it could be your shirt it could be
your facial hair it could be a number of
things
that could be distracting from your
material
that if you did say it in a collared
shirt
it may be funnier than if you set it in
a tank top
type deal so yeah your appearance does
play a part in your set
and it's something to be mindful of but
you know i mean
in my early days i had a mustache and i
was wearing goodwill clothes
and t-shirts i used to wear no cap
goodwill dress pants that were like
parachute pants
i wore some rock ports that were like
yellow
and um goodwill collared shirts ah this
is eddie bauer
now all right we hit the big time we're
on to the redneck ralph lauren now
um goodwill collard shirts or t-shirts
or i had like a michael jordan shirt i
mean i was just all over the place
but i was just focused on stage time and
honing that craft
and not worried about the appearance yet
i just wanted to just get funny first
i was just trying to figure out how to
create a setup punch you know
i didn't have time to figure out what my
wardrobe was going to be that evening
but it does i can honestly say it does
make a difference and one of my favorite
quotes about appearance is from dion
sanders
who said um you look good you play good
they pay good so keep that in mind
when you're performing and how you're
coming off to the audience if your beard
is it scraggly beard or is it more of a
groomed beard
all that can play into how your jokes
come off
and it all starts with self-awareness
[Music]